hey everyone how's it going it's your
boy definition here with a non spoiler
review for one switch yet the times they
are a-changin so I was lucky enough to
get to see all of you season 2 this week
and yeah we've got some stuff to talk
about I will be doing a spoiler filled
breakdown when the show launches on
Boxing Day but in the meantime I thought
I'd just go over my opinions on the new
season and whether it's worth checking
out or you know if you should give this
one a Miss so yeah this is either gonna
make you cancel Christmas or go round
and see the relatives you know the ones
you hate so you season two picks up
after the events of the first season
with the character having up sticks and
moved to LA in the wake of Canas
confronting him at the bookstore Joe or
rather will has changed his identity now
and is trying to basically change his
personality as well and suppress all of
the obsessive and compulsive drives that
basically led to the collapse of his
last relationship will wants to avoid
love at all costs and the C's move to
the one place where everyone's still in
love with themselves that it makes it
difficult for them to love anyone else
however this gets challenged when he
bumps into a woman appropriately named
love who seems to be throwing herself at
him and the season kind of centers
around their relationship with will
carving out a new identity and all of
the problems that come with that will
one small play by Penn Badgley is
excellent as the protagonist and similar
to the first season he actually has a
lot of charm and a level of charisma
that makes him easy to like even though
he's a very bad guy the inner monologues
are back in full force and will is
basically like the Sherlock Holmes of
stalkers picking apart all aspects of a
scenario and using them to his advantage
in order to manipulate his victims into
liking him I don't want to give away too
much but the new setting of LA it throws
a few curveballs at him and it's as
gripping as always watching him being
thrown into scenarios where he has to
basically think his way out of them
and a lot of the time the character only
gets out by the skin of his teeth now
one of the big aspects of the first
season was back and no this season
doesn't bring out all the answers as to
what really happened to her they do pass
out certain parts of the plot
masterfully so that you're in a constant
mood of oh I'll just watch one more
episode which yeah it's a really good
thing for Netflix that being said a lot
of major elements and cliffhangers of
the first season they kind of take a
backseat throughout the first half of
this one and primarily the focus here is
on love and her brother 40 who they both
kind of fight over the attention of
world throughout the entry love is an
almost polar opposite to back at some
points and where the latter was reserved
and very secure in herself love seems
vulnerable at several points and she
wears a heart on a sleeve she's played
brilliantly by Victoria pedretti you may
recognize as the bent neck lady from the
haunting of Hill House and she gives a
brilliant performance being far more
likable than back due to how open she is
her brother 40 played by James Scully is
great too and it's a real compliment to
the cast that everyone does a brilliant
job with the material that they have
everyone here is just far more likable
than the characters in the first season
and this makes it a much easier watch
however where the season drops a bit is
that it does feel very similar to the
first entry in a lot of ways there's
even the reuse of some plot aesthetics
such as the cage which makes a lot of
reappearances and an impressionable
young neighbor that will sort of becomes
a guardian angel - personally I didn't
mind this at all as for me it's about
the execution but I can see some fans
getting a bit of deja vu now the series
is full and I mean full of twists those
last two episodes are just yet they're
all over the place just as you get
comfortable with a certain pot element
they tend to shove another one in and it
constantly keeps not only will but also
the audience on their toes this is
really the essence of you and what made
the first series so great and here they
really turn it up to 11 having some
massive moments that come out of that
field when you don't expect them at all
also the ending is brilliant and it
really
be wanting more as I mentioned earlier
you know this season was sort of a
repeat in some ways however the way they
leave it's very clear that next time
there'll be a lot of change ups and this
definitely kept me interested this is a
show that's difficult to talk about
without really going into some of the
big plot reveals and I have a huge list
of plot points that I'm not allowed to
talk about but yeah I will say that you
will enjoy the show massively if you
here to see how messed up things can
really get this is a brilliant
production and in my opinion they really
knocked out of the park again and yet if
you were a huge fan of the first season
then I think you'll be over the moon
with this one as it Apes it in many ways
and even builds upon a lot of the plot
points showing what Joe really did to
Candice and giving her a reason to want
to ruin his life
you season two is the perfect
continuation of season one and being
this bad has never been this good which
propels the show above most I'm
definitely gonna revisit it when it's
fully out on Netflix and I think people
will over to and that's why I get a 9
out of 10
now obviously I'd love to you if you're
excited for you season 2 and make sure
you drop your fan theories and stuff in
the comment section below as I
absolutely love to read them make sure
you stay locked to the channel for the
you spoiler talk review which will be
out on Boxing Day and if you enjoy this
video then please give it a thumbs up
and make sure you check out our full
breakdown of the Watchmen finale which
would be linked at the end go over
everything that you need to know about
it pointing out all of the Easter eggs
giving our predictions for the future
and it's definitely worth checking out
if you want to know more if you want to
come chat to me after the video that
make sure you follow me on twitter at
definition whitey will head over to my
discord server which would be linked in
the description below we drop videos on
there early so if you want to see stuff
before anyone else and that's the best
place to be it's free to join and we
have an awesome community so hopefully I
see you over there very soon we're also
giving away a free copy of Joker which
is one of our favorite movies of the air
and all you have to do to be in with the
chance of winning is like the video make
'shy subscribe to the channel and leave
your thoughts on you season 1 in the
comment section
hello but when it's gonna be chosen at
random on the 15th of January and the
cell be shipped out from the intima get
surprised it's the best of luck to
everyone who takes part this is the
channel for people who are never missing
television so if that's the kind of
thing you like you need to subscribe to
definition thanks again for taking the
time to watch this you've been the best
and I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
[Music]